all right
hey you guys we're doing movie
retrospective again
yeah this is a good one hour photo man i
had forgotten how kick-ass
and awesome this movie was i this movie
impressed me when i saw it
back in what was it 2000 2002 2002 yeah
i was like man this is this movie's
[ __ ] great uh
but but i didn't realize it i didn't
realize it would age
this well it's going to be fantastic
this is a masterpiece
oh yeah big time yeah so the thing about
this one um
i think is it was it louie or michael
that sent us this
sentences on blu-ray um yeah one of you
two guys did i
you know apologize because if i can't
remember but
yeah so i had put it in the uh the polls
and finally
yeah i think it might have been as well
yeah um and we put it in the patreon
poll and it finally got voted on this
week so i was very excited because i had
really been
wanting to revisit it i saw this
in the theater when it came out back in
2002 i distinctly remember going and see
it in the theater
and the thing about this is that this
and the movie insomnia um which i
believe came out the same year as this
these were kind of like the first two
movies where you saw
robin williams in
a real serious or more like a villainous
role
i guess because he'd been in some
serious movies before but he still had
like a little bit of his
you know kind of i guess his robin
williams schtick kind of thing going on
still
yeah he was trying to broaden his uh his
repertoire
and you know it was real unusual to kind
of cast robin williams
as a villain although i don't think this
guy is like
i don't think this particular character
is is
an actual villain i think it's it's kind
of a mixed bag
yeah because he does do bad things but
you can understand why he does and he
does have like a sympathetic side
he's mentally ill yeah so you actually
can
you know you actually can't understand
where he's coming from and feel sorry
for him
even though you don't advocate what he's
doing
obviously because it's super weird and
creepy it's about this guy he's kind of
a loner
well he is a loner no family at least
doesn't show the
any family in a uh no family connections
you know what i mean
in his personal life works basically
works at
at walmart all right they don't use the
word walmart i think it's just called
save smart
something like that works at walmart and
uh he's
the photo technician they had these back
in the day you know some of you guys are
probably too young
some some of you guys might be too young
to attack nationals what the hell is
that
back in the day you had to take
photographs out of a camera
take them to walmart and get to get the
film developed
yeah and it was expensive and most of
the photos [ __ ] came out shitty
you know paying for photos that weren't
any of that weren't any good
so it was always kind of weird you know
taking your photos to get developed
because you weren't sure was somebody
else looking at your photos yeah they
were looking at your photos
well that's it and they kind of addre
they kind of address this a little bit
on there where he's talking about some
of his um regular
customers yeah and it's like you know
you always have like the amateur
pornographer
yeah because i'm like didn't anybody
figure out like to take porny pictures
duh polaroid but um that was the thing
the quality was bad but the yeah
good the quality why don't you learn to
develop your own film in your own dark
room it doesn't really
yeah i feel like anybody that's doing
like super like really boring
things would would uh you know kind of
invest in their own
developing things i was on i was on
yearbook staff so i
me and me and another guy we developed
all the photos for
for the yearbook back when i was in
brazil
so i don't know developing photos didn't
seem like a big deal to me you know it's
kind of fun
it is kind of fun i i did that in um in
junior high i guess i took like a whole
photography thing where they you know
they had a whole dark room set up and
you learned how to
man you learned how to do remember you
used to have to take the film out of the
thing like you had to put your
hands through this little bag like in a
little black bag that had
like [ __ ] uh you know stuff around
your wrist and you had to like go in
there and feel around so it didn't get
any light in it and all this other kind
of crap
so robin williams plays this guy he
doesn't seem to have any family
connections he uh he works uh
photo development and it's like his life
he's like
super good at it he's training other
people
but he was started to live vicariously
through a client
their photographs with their family
photos would come in
and he was kind of like real envious
of this guy with his wife and the kid
and he wished he had a family
because he didn't have family he's about
50 so i guess that time passed him by
and he didn't
have a family so he wanted to have a
family so he starts stalking him
it's [ __ ] it's pretty awesome and as
[ __ ] [ __ ]
starts to unfold it turns out the dude
that he's
envious over he wishes he had this
family turns out that dude
is screwing around on his wife yeah and
that just shatters his whole [ __ ]
world view because
this guy's got something that you know
he would [ __ ] die for
and he's just throwing it away on this
damn
affair a side piece so he kind of goes
on a mission to kind of rectify this
it doesn't work that's spoiler alert
yeah it doesn't go the way a bunch of
weird [ __ ] happens in the movie
and really i walked away from this movie
[ __ ]
it confirmed it was confirmed to me that
this movie is a [ __ ] masterpiece
it looks great the way it's shot it's
real
sterile and futuristic looking even
though it's only it's a shot and it was
probably shot in 2000 2002 by that time
yeah it looks it's aged super well it
looks
futuristic but it looks futuristic in a
way that a dead
mall looks futuristic it's just a trip
real good score
touches of touches of industrial music
in there you know
going on in the background it's just a
lot of suspense in it real good acting
and i'm convinced after watching this
flick now
is that michael fassbender's name yeah
michael fassbender the guy that played
uh
david david from prometheus from
prometheus you see she remembered she
could think for me
from prometheus um i think he looked at
this movie in this character to
try to help him build the character of
david because
it just seems like a lot of the same
there are some similarities
and the way he moves because this guy's
doesn't know how to be a real person
he's just trying to
act like a a normal person and that's
the way that robot was from prometheus
he did he wanted to be a real person but
yeah it's kind of hard to do that when
you're a robot
you know i mean so i think he saw this
movie and
i think it helped him build that he very
well might have because you know the
more when you pointed it out
and i was watching i was like yeah it
does seem like there's a lot of
similarities between
that i mean it could be just a
coincidence but i don't really know
mannerisms a lot of the same delivery
you know the um
highly polished highly professional you
know
speech patterns and trying to be kind of
generic
trying to take something generic and
make that
like a good thing you know what i'm
talking about he was trying to be real
official
that's what what it was like and
everything was sterile and generic yeah
and the thing about it to hide what it
really was
yeah and what it really was is he was
kind of a loser you know
yeah but like i said he's not i think
that's really good because it's really
hard to pull off
a character like this um this was
written and directed by
mark romanek in case i didn't uh say who
hasn't done a [ __ ] set of movies he
actually does a lot of music videos
he did um you know when johnny cash
covered that uh the trent reznor song
hurt
yeah in that video like which was really
iconic yeah he directed that
and um so you can definitely see and i
think too the cinematographer for this
because the cinematography in this
is so good it's in the framing of the
shots it's just it's really really nice
looking
i think the cinematographer i can't
remember what his name was but it might
have been the same dude that worked with
like
a lot of like david fincher's movies
like you know fight club and uh
yeah [ __ ] like that and there's
something about the color palette just
the way
the way the shot composition is the
color palette and the filters
everything looks real sterile and
corporate
and i think it works they're also kind
of trying to contrast
whenever they show robin williams
character whose name is psy
parish they call himself the photo guy
yeah um
i think they're trying to show one how
sterile his life is
um and how empty his life is because
everything is
white or cream-colored um you know
there's just
he has there's no color in his life
there's no joy in his life there's no
and it's kind of contrasted with the
shots that you see of the family that he
stalks the yorkin family
who it's it's all done in like real warm
rich
um you know colors like saturated woods
yeah yeah yeah like a real natural the
thing with size i called him a loser but
it's not really his fault he's just a
very empty character
you find out more about him later i'm
not gonna steal the movie's thunder
but he's just a very
lonely character very lonely yeah
of course it's going to have a very and
he's he's in a very sterile corporate
environment where he works he doesn't
really have
friends and his boss is the same guy out
of office space that does the
yeah can you come in on can you come on
i'm gonna need you to come back
that guy plays his boss i feel like that
dude is like so typecast yeah
it's like you know it's like anytime you
need some [ __ ] corporate boss it's
like call that dude up that's not yeah
yeah i think i'm gonna need you
okay yeah yeah that guy
and um yeah and of course
and once again he knocks it out of the
park in this movie he does a [ __ ] he
does a great job doesn't have a big cast
i was like man what kind of car is that
it's a toyota echo
and it shows him driving that 2000
toyota echo around a lot and it's this
little bitty economy car
cream colored with the interior and it
just
it ends up being kind of like a
character in the movie in a way
because he's in it a lot yeah and it
kind of
on all this stocking activities yeah and
there's something like about that car
kind of personifies him it's just a bare
minimalist
car you know what i mean and it's white
and it's
cream and white and it just looks very
corporate and
not much personality and and it's like
you know it's like it's like a poor
guy's non-descript car
it's not a bad car yeah it's just like a
poor guy's
perfect car they're trying to make him i
guess they were trying to make him look
like bloodless and like washed out
because they were just trying to show
that not a lot of personality
yeah that he was that his life was just
empty and everything everyone's
very generic yeah like even even his
apartment when they show his apartment
it's like all the walls are
cream-colored it's like there's nothing
there's not a lot of furniture there's
not a lot of anything
all that's in there is this massive
collage
of all of the photographs that he's
stolen
from yeah because every time this family
comes in
because he's been developing their
photos for a really long time because if
you see some of the ones like
you know just when their kid was a baby
and like almost a decade yeah
because it was the kids nine and you
know so he had pictures of like when the
kid was born and everything
and for all of that time every time that
family comes in
to get their pictures developed he makes
an extra set for himself
and then he takes them home and puts
them in this big [ __ ] collage
the weird thing about this movie and
like i said i think this is why
a character like this is really hard to
pull off because like i said you don't
want him
too pathetic um
because people that will turn people off
you don't want him too sympathetic
because he is kind of a villain like i
mean
in the in the sense that he he does
really bad things that he shouldn't be
doing
but i just feel like he threaded that
needle so well
that even when he does [ __ ] that
maybe like another actor or something
like that did like like
for example the scene where he turns up
at the kids
soccer match yeah and he's like watching
the kid and he gives him a toy and stuff
it just it feels like in the hands of
another actor or maybe in another movie
everybody'd be like woo perv alert you
know what to be like like creepy and
stuff but he doesn't
really give that vibe off they made sure
that you you that
you're not sure of this guy's motives
yeah they made sure that you're not you
don't know we're spoiling it here
well i mean like i said this is a
retrospective so this movie is
you know all 20 years old so when i was
watching it
it kept i kept thinking it was going to
go really sideways
but it didn't that was another thing too
that i actually really like about it
really
bad and it didn't get that bad and i
think that's because you don't know who
he is
right yeah they don't give a lot of his
backstory like at the end you know he
does kind of give a little bit but they
even then it's all kind of like
implication and
so they don't go a lot into his
backstory you just kind of have to fill
in the blanks yourself which i kind of
like i like that they left it kind of
vague
another thing that i like about this too
is that this could have gone i
i like how restrained this movie is i
like that it very well could have gone
because there's i've been other
thrillers about like you know
a loner weirdo that like is stalking
somebody or whatever this is not the
first time yeah that's everything
it's crazy but it doesn't go off the
rails where it's like oh now he's like
murdering everybody yeah he's doing this
it really isn't it's it's very grounded
it's very realistic like something that
would happen
yeah it just doesn't get crazy and i
like that about like that might
piss some people off i don't know
because they want to see more of
i guess more of a climax or it was
perfect in its time but yeah but i
really like that it's kind of
that it's very reserved what i think
what it was trying to do is that he was
the villain in the story
but he wasn't that bad he didn't think
he was the villain he thought he was the
good guy
right which that's the way it usually
goes down
he thought he was doing the right thing
uh
yeah i mean basically so what he thought
he was doing i think
was that he wasn't trying and another
thing i liked too like i said they
didn't make it so that he was like
perving on the kid he wasn't perving on
the mom
you weren't sure at first yeah you
weren't they made it so
you suspected he was pervert on the mom
then you thought he was pervert on the
kid
turns out he wasn't perving on any of
them no he's it was a totally different
yeah
he honestly just wanted to insert
himself into the family he wanted to be
uncle sai yeah he just wanted to and
then he wanted to save the family
which maybe ultimately he did
i think that i think that might have
been the implication or one of the
implications at the end of the movie
is that he did kind of end up saving the
family yeah and he gets in big trouble
but that was his sacrifice i think he's
it didn't actually it didn't actually
come out and say it but it did show kind
of like shots of all the family together
with him kind of in it yeah so i guess
he did
save the family i mean i think that was
his imagination though because
it does kind of go in and out where yeah
maybe he just thought he saved the phone
yeah because remember how like that long
sequence where he's sitting out in front
of the house and then suddenly he's in
there
yeah he thought he was in the house he
was and he's like walking around the
house looking at all their [ __ ] like
taking a dump in their toilet
yeah you know also there's kind of stuff
but then it turned out that you know and
then you see the family come in and
you're like oh [ __ ] he got caught but
then they don't react or they're just
like hey uncle sai what's up
so you then you know it's kind of like
in his head
and he really seems that's i think what
makes him so sympathetic
is that he doesn't have murderous
designs
he doesn't want to rape anybody he
doesn't want he just wants to be
involved he wants to you know sit on the
couch and have this family come home
and he's just like an extended part of
their family that's all he wants
because i guess what the implication was
from the end of the stuff like after he
gets caught and like the cop is
interviewing him and stuff
was that he never had that when he was a
kid so it's almost kind of like
i saw somebody point this out and this
was actually probably a really um
astute observation was that he was
actually
trying to not replace the kid
but he was trying to make himself you
know
one of the kids like he was going back
in time like to
make of the childhood that he never had
because his family was super [ __ ] up
and they
were terrible to him so he wanted to
you know have this perfect family that
he
never had yeah so it's all yeah so i so
i think that's kind of what he was doing
he wasn't interested in usurping anyone
he wasn't interested
he just wanted to be a part of this
family because he had never had that
i remember after seeing the movie you
know back in 2002 2003 i didn't see it
in the movies i
can't remember where i saw it i think i
rented it or something um
after seeing the movie it kind of was
under the impression that maybe robin
williams had a dart
had like a dark side to him yeah turns
out you know
he had killed himself later maybe yeah
he did i guess he did
they said he had serious depression
problems which makes you think that he
might have kind of fell for this felt
for this character he might have had
something
in common with him in terms of feelings
of isolation or something
oh i definitely think that he was
bringing something of himself
to this role which is a great role man
it's a great role it's a great movie
it really is and it's just you know it
it's this whole thing where like because
there was something else i was going to
say too about
um the another theme of the movie too
and it's interesting because even though
you know this is from 2002
when digital cameras were just starting
to
make inroads into i mean most people
were still had
film cameras and you still took your you
know pictures to be developed
obviously but digital cameras were just
starting to
kind of come on the market and we're
trying to you know we're just starting
to get like
cheap enough that you know regular
people could have them
so so i feel like people nowadays
that did that have only known digital
photos that that might be a little like
weird to them or off-putting because
it's like a whole other technology
doesn't really exist all that much
anymore
but that said one theme of this movie i
think is still really relevant and
actually is maybe more relevant nowadays
than it was back then
which is the whole thing where he was
talking about
people taking pictures only of happy
things or
things they want other people to see
it's like nobody takes pictures of
things that they want to forget
so he was so so there's a thread running
through this movie
of the things you see in pictures are
always kind of like
the idealized version of what is
actually going on which like i said in
the
in the age of social media that's
probably more relevant than ever
yeah although there is no social mood
media in this movie at all it's
pre-social media yes and there's
something about that tone that it just
works for me yeah
you know what i mean there's just it
takes me back to that time
so guys like psy could exist they did
exist yeah
i don't think they exist to the same
amount you know in the same numbers as
they
maybe maybe they just look at other
people's [ __ ] and so i can go man i
don't have that
you know but it's just uh i don't think
people were as isolated
yeah they're as isolated today as they
were but yeah i mean i think there's a
lot more outlets for people nowadays
than maybe back then because like you
said i mean he just was kind of sitting
around watching tv
yeah you know drinking a beer
compartment all by himself he was
watching this
[Laughter]
but yeah so that so that was kind of the
thing so i thought that was an
interesting
take also as i said it's very relevant
kind of social media
where everybody has all these like look
at all this [ __ ] that i'm doing like
putting up on my instagram and it's like
that's not
you're not showing like all the unhappy
[ __ ] that happens in your life you know
what i mean
so i think that that's still really
relevant now and that's kind of
that's kind of what made him go off the
deep end
was not only finding out that the dad of
the supposedly perfect family was
[ __ ] around and he actually found out
because he developed the mistresses
film film and saw him in it like
smooching on her and so
so just the fact of that happened and
then him getting fired at the same time
because he finally got busted for
you know making all those uh copies
right
yeah because like i said over nine or
ten years making i mean
photo paper and [ __ ] like that back then
that was not cheap yeah um
so corporate would probably let you get
away with it for a while but then
they're just like hey this is a huge
discrepancy over 10 years
like every time he makes you know two
photos
per thing and looks like he just makes
extra ones yeah every single time or
that one family
so you know you'd think that they would
notice after a while and they did
um actually although i think and i
didn't realize this when i was watching
it
but i think because i'm sitting there
going man he was taking extra photos for
like 10 years so you think they would
have called him out on it before that
i think the reason that it came up was
because he got into an altercation with
that
with the dude that was repairing the
machine yeah because he was sitting
there going oh it's like a three per
like a point three percent cyan shift
and it's like fix it and the guy was
like yeah
yeah so i think that that might have
been what happened that he made that
dude mad
right so i think that's why that whole
scene was like was in there
makes sense now yeah so i didn't
reported the [ __ ] description yeah
like i said i don't think i put those
two things together like until
make sense later like i was thinking
about i was like oh that would have been
instigating so so him getting fired and
at around the same time
finding out that you know the dude was
[ __ ] around on his wife
and you know psy kind of thinking to
himself that
you know you have the perfect family
supposedly and you don't
appreciate it yeah um so he thought
that he was just gonna go and sort
everything out
yeah the movie the movie is not an
action movie but not at all but the way
it's edited
it seems like an action movie it it
unfolds very quickly
it shows you a lot of cool [ __ ] visually
the movie is [ __ ] real interesting
it's almost kind of kubrickian i was
thinking that too especially like that
really
that famous dream sequence where he's
standing in that white
in the uh in the aisle like in the store
and it's all empty and then like his
eyes start to bleed and all this other
kind of [ __ ] it's like super creepy it's
almost
kind of like something stanley kubrick
would do that's what i was thinking too
like we're gonna have weird
shots weird stillness and [ __ ] the
way the shots are set up and the color
palette and everything's just
it's it's it's very visual for a movie
that isn't an action movie
and there is like a couple little action
scenes uh
about him getting arrested and stuff um
yeah and the dream sequence and stuff i
mean it's it's fun to watch
it's good yeah it's just pulled me into
it it's a really
unsettling movie i think it's it's a
quiet movie but it has like
there's just something really unsettling
about it the tone it's the tone yeah
acting it's just real good i mean like i
said great score great
framing it's just a it's a beautiful
looking movie and
like i said i saw it in the theater back
in 2002 when it came out and i think i
saw it one more time
subsequently like years later but i
haven't seen it for probably 10
at least 10 years or more and i had
forgotten
how beautiful it was and i had forgotten
how
compelling it was you know what i mean
it's just
just the imagery and it's just this just
creepy creepy like atmosphere
but also really sad it's like a really
really sad story he's a really
sad character it's sad but a lot of
times sad movies are boring
and it's not like that you just got to
see it
it's it's pulls you into it because
williams pulls you into this story
because it's driven by this character
yeah that he is yeah and
he's kind of threatening in a way
but you kind of feel for him you know
what i mean yeah
and you're not really sure why you're
letting the story unfold
and yeah it's it's good real good it's a
masterpiece
yeah and as i said i think forgotten
pretty much
yeah it's not one that gets brought up a
lot um it seemed like it was a pretty
big uh
you know box office success it was like
a pretty moderate uh moderate success um
it only cost 12 million to make and it
made people talking about it it made
like 50 odd million
and like i said i think that a lot of
people point to this as probably
one of robin williams best roles if not
his best role and as i said this was
right around the time period when he was
just trying to
spread his acting wings and get out of
you know the comedic
thing and was trying to do more
dramatically so when you see you have
insomnia which as i said i believe came
out the same year as this i think
wasn't robert de niro in that i want to
say i saw it and it was good
but i think robert robin williams played
a serial killer in that
and the weird thing too and i had
forgotten all about this until i saw
somebody else mention it
robin williams was actually in another
movie which was very similar premise to
this one called final cut
and it's kind of like i think it was
more sci-fi because i think it was a
thing where
you could like there were these chips
that were in your
eyes and it recorded all your memories
and robin williams job in that movie was
to like when you died
was to edit together like all your best
memories that they would show at your
funeral
you know what i'm saying so it's like a
similar premise to this was like oh like
all the best
times of your life or anything and i
remember seeing it like when somebody
brought it up i was kind of like oh yeah
i remember seeing that with the eyes i
remember that
so it's like seemed like a really uh
similar premise to this
and um i remember that one being really
good as well but it's just really
interesting to me how someone like robin
williams who like i said you know
made his fortune in comedy a lot of
times these dudes
that are really high up in in the comedy
world
um when you give them a really good
meaty dramatic role
they just knock it right out of the
[ __ ] park yeah i mean look at
something like adam sandler or something
like that who's
you know whose comedy movies are just
like stupid as [ __ ] man i thought james
was the [ __ ] but yeah but then you see
something like uncut gems or spanglish
or something like that whereas
like the dude can [ __ ] act yeah and
it's just it's crazy like to think that
it's
so it's crazy to think that robin
williams who
was kind of known as like this coked up
kind of crazy that was kind of his
shtick for a really long time
and then when they gave him roles like
this like a really quiet role where he
just had to be
just this flat affect like through the
whole thing and he just
really really pulled it off yeah what
was what's kind of impressive is that
robert williams is not a physically
imposing guy
but in this movie he's he he kind of has
a
cuts kind of a sinister figure yeah he
can do something bad
it's good good movie and as i said you
should probably see insomnia too if you
haven't i remember that being
also very good and like i said he plays
a killer in that one um
and i and i remember that really working
as well so uh maybe that's one that we
have bicentennial man yeah yeah i
remember that
i remember not liking that but i haven't
seen it for a long time so i don't
really know
i don't really want to say it because i
i just remember kind of seeing it and
being like
what okay but uh yeah so again i'm
pretty sure that louis sent us this
um so thank you very much for sending if
it was michael i'm sorry
whoever it was thank you very much for
sending this and i'm really really glad
that we got to see it again
and that we got to talk about it a
little bit with you guys so if you
haven't seen it one hour photo
came out in 2002 yeah and got to see it
yeah you got to see it it's really
really good
so uh yeah that'll do it for this review
and we'll see on the next one
bye